yeah what it do welcome to another
episode of real mature to show we make
about things you do when you grow up and
one of the things you do when you grow
up is you get to know your family in a
different way so we have three different
videos we made about people getting to
know their families and the first one is
kind of starts with me except so that's
why there's like no one else here but
usually there's like another person so
we're just gonna get into it you guys
ready you ready Jenni you ready well
let's do it so the first video we want
to show you actually started with
another much worse idea for a video that
our team had uh basically my parents are
coming into the office I manage this
team and everyone was like wouldn't it
be funny if we make a video where we get
to ask Henry's parents questions about
Henry I'd love to see your impressions
of him hey I'm Henry oh no no my
impression of Henry I don't have my
phone is texting on a scale of one to
ten how much do you want Henry to get
married detail really so one interesting
thing happened which is our friend Mark
didn't really understand the idea of the
thing he didn't ask my parents an
embarrassing question he just asked a
question he wanted to know about life
and my parents kind of had like a really
interesting answer is it worth having
kids of course it is there's nothing in
the world like it every parent I hear
every parents say that about having kids
like the tough parts as a downside is
every parent worries some about their
kids you know wants them to have a good
life want somebody be happy when things
don't go well for them they don't go
well for parents so I mean it that's a
reflection of love but it's also
sometimes sometimes tough we thought
it'd be interesting if we just got
people to call their parents and ask
them a question they never thought to
ask and see if we could all learn
something about
and you know get to know our parents a
little bit better all right but first we
have a video that calling me Colin tell
us about that video we got contacted by
a woman who got thrown into a pretty
interesting living dynamic where she got
to know her siblings pretty well can you
are here tomorrow that's yeah hey that
was pretty vague I like that it's nice
okay was it delicious go to the video
yeah fine
so this time last year I was working
full time I was living in my own
apartment with my two best friends and
just kind of had a normal life priority
was all just kind of about work and
doing that early 20 thing of trying to
move up and I was doing that I got a
call from a friend who was over at my
dad's house he's been sick since I was 7
years old it kept going up and down he
had prostate cancer so I didn't
necessarily think it was a big deal I
thought she was just getting nervous
about the way he always was everything
changed I left my job my mother just was
incapable of parenting before he went
into the hospital my dad had asked me to
take care of the twins if he passed away
nobody that I know is being raised by
their sisters she guess is pretty cool
I was definitely for lack of better
terms probably a little bit more on the
selfish side okay Charlotte had actually
moved home to save up money to travel
around the world and so now I'm sharing
a room with a 15 year old girl and it's
different so obviously in this day and
age if you're faced with a problem the
first thing you do is Google and there
was nothing there I think that's
actually white is he started doing the
blog also because she couldn't find
anything online just talk about what
we're doing so next time someone else
goes through this there's something to
reach out to and something to read about
at least the daily experience of it all
it's cool it's cool that is actually
within a matter of months is it's
helping people normally we're on the
same page about everything and we're
really good at when the twins ask for
something big that we know they're going
to hold us to we'll say oh I have to
talk to I have to talk to Charlotte
first or she'll say oh I have to talk to
Isabel first and as long as we do that
we're fine I couldn't imagine just not
being part of this to be honest like me
and as well definitely had like our
moments where we were like debating not
living together in this situation the
question was never am I gonna leave the
raising the kids part it's just how do
we make it work we're mean as well or in
a situation where we're getting along
Charlotte and I have had our ups and
downs through this but I don't know what
I'd do without her like we co-parent I
legally have guardianship but it's a lot
of work for one person I'm older by
three minutes he always says it's two
but I'm sure it's three it's probably
safe it's three I think that at the
beginning it was really you know
learning how to make sure that all the
bills were paid on time and like
actually being like a head of household
rather than just like a 23 old girl with
an apartment that I pay like rent
electricity and gas you know it's like
now there's budgeting for food and like
budgeting for like making sure that they
have clothes on their backs
and random school projects that come up
and just like making sure that all of
your Ducks are in a row before you need
them to be in a row which is it's
daunting
about this one sure that's the one word
is most upset that I was being born do
we have to do this but I was the best
dad you didn't love anyone in the world
more than he loved us no matter where he
was he was telling people about his kids
and what they were up to even when they
didn't want to listen at his funeral
everyone's telling stories and one
person was like I just remember this one
time that we had a party bus and Harvey
was like passing line out to the people
on the street he knew how to walk into
the room and own it and how to talk to
everybody and how to make everyone feel
better about themselves it was just he
was a cool dude
it was really fun I miss him there's the
thought of what life should be first
what life is but that's not a way to
live a life I just try to do it was good
a job as he did for us with the twins
which is pretty high bar that was a cool
video a Kahn's been working on that for
a long time so next I'm gonna go see if
Hillary wants to call her parents and
ask them another question about life
hey guys hey
calling Hillary's mom you guys very anti
being in videos ah this is Henry hi nice
to meet you miss do is switch the I we
flip the phone so it's sideways okay
yeah yeah so so we're doing this thing
where we're having people just call
their parents and ask them questions
that they normally wouldn't ask and
Hillary has a question which we picked
out for her which she's gonna ask you
and then we just love to hear your
answer okay okay
how do you think you are different from
me when you were my age well I was much
more conservative much more concerned
about pleasing other people than myself
doing the right thing and I was Lac
straighter and and that's it do you wish
you had been more like Hillary's now
when you were her age I would love to be
like Hillary every possible way she's my
idol and very very proud to be her
mother
oh thanks mom cool that's it that's the
saga yeah I guess you've heard enough
from me yeah wonderful thank you so much
for doing it
the bad kids yeah hey love you Bella
bye so the next video is a video that
Jenny made about getting know her family
Jenny what was your video back
well I'm CUBAN my whole family's Cuban
and my grandfather along with my family
came to the states about 60 years ago
and this is about finding something that
was once lost
Yacouba we have two ladies from Miami
here to tell us a little bit about Cuban
food Dimitri and I I'm just an idiot I
am an idiot we Jews an idiot we have
never really experienced Cuban food we
don't know what the hell's going yeah
I'm gonna eat off all of your plates if
that's all right yeah of course Ali have
you ever been to Cuba I have not and you
have also not been to Cuba some of my
family members are planning a trip in
the not-too-distant future so it's
possible things are changing it's
definitely something I've wanted to do
all my life
so that sort of brings us to why we're
here a couple of weeks ago Jenny and I
were on a shoot together for a video I
was making about meeting my neighbors
and while we were stuck in traffic and
dis chatting Jenny mentioned to me that
her grandfather used to be a painter and
that all of his paintings were somewhere
in Cuba and they had no idea where the
local movie theaters would hire him to
draw like Clark Gable and John Wayne and
all these like famous American stars
they had to leave every single one with
different neighbors and family members
scattered about Cuba and he's been gone
since 1959 58 yeah since you took that
Peter Pan flight and now he's 93 about
to be 93 in August yes so when he got to
America what happened that he gave up
painting they weren't in a good position
in Cuba so it was a much worse situation
in Miami one of my cousins from Cuba she
got a Facebook account and we just
started talking found out that one of
our neighbors kept probably the painting
that meant the most my grandfather Ianto
Sano's hace que que tiene quadrants ooh
bo Derek en la Gazza promedio seguida yo
y como fue ago no siap intone que lo que
lo hizo vecino que la entonces cuando yo
se da Mooji se para esto sonido de se
que viva la cual a nosotros que era muy
hermoso Cano de mano de bajo siempre -
vino muy entonces a que mis Manos de
Havana a given un amigo mio que se diga
a la vent a comprar cuadernos evo lamp
rattle Cinderella cuento e y me fraccion
se todo por el le dije no yellow vent
okay so pimento dinner precio pukenga
regalo amigo que ella que de jamon
omaima's otra persona my future echoes
Evita shaquita no estado be my pubic a
low age and they haven't talked to him
in years like the last time they saw him
he was like 26 like our age you know you
guys have any questions at this point is
sort of like an Auburn okay I'm riveted
yeah it turns out that he drew this
apparently when he was 17 years old it
was one of his first paintings he's 93
now so that's like late 30s we have
cousins that
moved to Miami from Cuba about five
years ago but they still travel
frequently to Cuba when we found out
that the painting was so in existence we
talked to him and he's like well I'm
going to a wedding he was very nervous
about still trying to take that through
the airport because it's still right
smuggling yes yeah he rolled it up and
put it into a duffel bag but then some
funny things happened mm-hmm there's
more yeah I'm gonna get weird just that
short trip from Cuba to Miami it broke
into pieces it was a jigsaw puzzle my
closest closest my bestest friend I said
can you put this together he did it like
about three days and there's that
painting like on the table and there was
still pieces missing like little scraps
or like oh that's the end of the nervous
that's the end of the tail or that's the
corner of this and you know you know
keep erasing hey Sierra Madre de hacer
esto my grandfather is a very it keeps
his emotions to himself and he was you
know more quiet but you can just read it
off of him two three smile for me I love
it
you were just more floored than anything
I'm like my heart is pounding is that
okay right now where is the painting
right now it's hanging in my
grandparents house for your grandfather
this is something that has been his
grandchild abut now like another
generation it's still connected to Cuba
and it's still connected to that root I
think that's really powerful hey and if
anything changes over the next couple of
years people might be a place you can go
visit and see if you can find some more
of his paintings you guys enjoy your
food I'm not done yet
oh yeah even Gabon
yeah yeah 3d we were in the clean plate
Club over here come on Jenny
so now we're here with curly hey and
curly is going to cause mom and just
pull them out of the kitchen yeah hi
what's up
that's my little nephew I have a
question for you hi
oh this with my coworker all right mom
what is something you would change about
the way you raised me for you is
everything excellent
oh thanks mom all right how do you think
love changes over decades why do you
think changes you change a lot you know
I mean I mean marry with my husband for
33 years now you know you get married
for one day in that two days you do
divorce
my mom's a big fan of Kim Kardashian
what's the secret
what did you guys do what's the secret I
love him with things I love him now like
I met him yesterday
that's sweet mom all righty mom that was
great thanks mom bye Noah I love you
BYE MOM bye all right hey I mean do you
feel like do you wish you talk to your
mom like ask the questions like that
more often
oh yeah my mom yeah my mom I had like a
super tight with my dad with me my mom
had are like a little different
think about that everyone think about
the questions you wish you could ask
your parents and then maybe just ask him
yeah I don't ask calm enough it's good
for your grandparents see I do that with
my grandma actually yeah Studdard
grandparents are still with you don't
take it out on it
and with that we'll end this episode of
real mature what did you okay say what
it do what it do what it do yeah what
would it do what it do